it's been more than a decade since
hotshot rookie racer lightning McQueen
burst onto the big screen in the first
Cars movie now he's back in cars three
with the cast of new characters as well
as old favorites to get his life back on
track
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to uncover
some amazing secrets and facts about the
making of Pixar's latest animated movie
I'm also running my special cars three
giveaway on this video as well for a
chance to be one of two lucky people
who'll win this very cool the art of
cars three hardback book featuring
Pixar's fabulous concept art storyboards
and insights into the movie all you need
to do is subscribe and leave a comment
about the film and also answer the
question I'll be asking later in the
video many years of work go into each of
Pixar's animated features and naturally
over the course of those years
screenplays and character designs go
through numerous changes in fact during
the production of cars three artists
created over 80,000 storyboards for the
film however only around ten thousand of
those made it into the final movie but
thankfully sometimes the animators on a
new movie can make use of the good work
done by their colleagues on a previous
Pixar film for example when you look at
the sky in cars three 85% of those
clouds you see actually came from the
cloud library for the good dinosaur
although sadly screen legend Paul Newman
died back in 2008 his cars character Doc
Hudson still plays a crucial part in the
new movie and doc is voiced once again
by Newman himself thanks to many hours
of conversations between the renowned
actor and Cars director John Lasseter
there were caught on tape during voice
recording sessions for the first movie a
lot of what Paul Newman and John
Lasseter talked about between takes was
racing related so when the filmmakers
trawled through those recordings looking
for material that would work for cars
three they had a veritable treasure
trove of dialogue to choose from when
the animators were working out how
lightning McQueen's face should move
they look to Owen Wilson the voice actor
behind the car for inspiration which
means that the way lightning mooses
mouth in the movie is based on the shape
of Owen Wilson's mouth when he talks
including the way the actor curls and
purses his lips the movie's design team
wanted the look of next gen racer
Jackson storm to be incomplete
contrast the look of Lightning McQueen
so they went for a sharp angular design
for Jackson which stands out compared to
lightnings more rounded flowing look in
fact Jackson's storm is actually how the
Pixar team think a stock car racer will
look 20 years from now as for the S
symbol on Jackson's side that's based on
the International hurricane symbol which
has been tweaked stretched and color
matched to give him a sleek and bold
look and to contrast with a lightning
bolt on number 95 for the appearance of
school bus miss fritter the filmmakers
took a subtle style cue from oranges any
black star Lea delaria who voices a
demolition derby champ yes just look at
miss fritters face and you'll notice
that the animators increase the thick
rubber trim around her windshield
in a hat tip to de la Rio's trademark
thick rimmed glasses on top of that miss
fretted smokestacks are another cool
easter egg as their design is based on
the horns of the classic Disney
character Maleficent who featured in the
1959 animation Sleeping Beauty as well
as the 2014 live-action movie starring
Angelina Jolie by the way for more
awesome Easter eggs and cars 3 tap the
top right of the screen to check out my
video on that when it came to bringing
to life the movie's crazy demolition
derby with all its mud and dust flying
everywhere
the filmmakers discovered how difficult
it was to make computer animated mud
that was the right consistency so it
looked realistic but didn't totally
cover up the characters to give you an
idea of just how big a task this was for
the artists and technicians working on
cars 3 there are actually 616 shots in
the movie that feature merged splatters
sand dust and dirt one of the things the
filmmakers did to ensure they got the
right design and feel for the scene
overall was to visit a night race on a
dirt track after that it was a matter of
trial and error to get the mud looking
less like cake icing or liquid chocolate
which is how it looked in early tests a
more like the combination of chunky
oatmeal and soup that director Brian fee
wanted when cars 3 production designer
JC ster joined Pixar back in the early
2000s one of the first things he had to
do was design a pay phone that could
function for a large mechanical object
that had no hands like a car Schuster's
payphone design ended up being cut from
the first Cars movie however in a little
nod to the production designer the pay
phone has been reintroduce
in cars three so remember to look out
for it during the scene at Flo's v-eight
café a chance encounter with a vintage
car rally during a meeting that the Cars
3 team had away from their Pixar offices
gave the filmmakers the idea to pay
tribute to the history of racing and
early NASCAR races in their movie among
the characters in the film based on
real-life NASCAR legends is Louise
Barnstormer Nash who is named after the
first lady of racing Louise Smith who
won 38 races in the 1940s and 50s and
who's Nash ambassador Karl ends its
number 94 to her cars three counterpart
NASCAR legend Wendell Scott who was the
first African American to win in the
grand national series also inspired the
cars three team to create a new
character called river Scott who races
under number 34 just like Wendell Scott
did also doc Hudson's old coach and
friend smokey who Lightning McQueen
turns to for help in his own career is
based on real-life racing legend the
innovative mechanic Henri smokey eunuch
who just like his namesake in the movie
ran an automobile repair shop that he
dubbed the best damn garage in town Owen
to emphasize the bond in the movie
between smokey and Doc Hudson he was a
Hudson Hornet the animators based smoked
his design on a Hudson pickup truck now
what was your favorite moment in cars 3
and who's your favorite character in the
cars movies for a chance to win this
awesome the art of car 3 hardback book
be sure to subscribe and leave a comment
about the movie and also answer the
following question which Disney
character is most fritters design a
reference to make sure you turn on your
notifications to get all my new cars 3
and Pixar videos and I'll be announcing
the winners for the giveaway on an
upcoming video congratulations to these
two winners of my recent alien covenant
giveaway if you're one of them send me a
message on youtube or via my email which
you can find on my about page so I can
get your details to send you the prize
if you enjoyed this I really appreciate
you hitting the thumbs up button and
check out some more of my Pixar a movie
secrets videos right here thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers